much different lineup that ryu will face
than what we saw in yesterday's game
bogart's waiting ryu deals and a
fastball in the air out to straight away
center field springer is on the run
getting to the track reaches out and he
makes the catch
jared richards six and seven era of 521
he's already made five starts against
toronto
so now here's corey dickerson one of the
new blue jays with a chance to put the
blue jays on in front 1-1 swinging a
line drive into right field of base in
springer sprints around third he's
coming to the plate stop sign for
hernandez going first to third on an rbi
base hit by corey dickerson a blue jay
strike first two out rbi base hit from
the bat of corey dickerson his third
with the lead
284 21 home run slumping badly right now
1-1 off the end of the bat flared here
comes gurilla that's going to drop down
for a base hit
debra's into third it gets away
here's the throw
off line and the red sox are on the
board and all the way down to third jd
martinez he is safely in guriel had all
sorts of trouble with that down that
left field line and the red sox tie it
up yeah jd hit that one off the end of
the bat right there i believe the bat
broke rafi actually hesitates rounding
third right there but again the throw
was offline
no shot at getting them here's a spot
for plucky here's a line drive in the
left field of base hit red sox lead two
to one
jd scores plucky stays hot and how good
must that feel oh my goodness what is
going on what is happening three hits in
a row two runs in an inning this is
crazy and these balls are being hit hard
defense in at the corners
squares to bun and bunsen in the air
bloody makes a heck of a play
left his feet the ball was in foul
territory and guerrero dove and made the
catch
what a play
boy see we have seen him make
outstanding plays all season long he is
getting more comfortable by the day
anticipating the bunt he sees the bunt
square around hard charging
takes it right off the dirt
and makes a great catch to help out his
pitcher with that one how about that
play you go back to june 27th kiki's
tied for the team home run lead with
nine
base hit into right field
here comes another run plowecki is in to
score
the red sox lead it three to one
yeah i think you're swinging the bat all
this inning and kiki picks up his 43rd
run bad at end
excellent job by [ __ ] right there
recognizing the pitch especially with o2
o2 count you're in protection mode you
got to cut down the swing we'd like to
see a long ball there but you're able to
do a job you recognize a fastball up and
out of the zone keeps the barrel deep
kevin fluecki comes up with runners at
first and third wide open stance he
singled in a run his first time the
pitch swinging a line drive into the gap
in left center field and that's going to
be extra bases coming home to score is
bogart devers is over to third it's a
double for plucky he just keeps on
hitting it is four one red sides well if
the conversation wasn't going on before
the game about giving kevin pollocki
more playing time sure it's gonna happen
now one away and still a golden
opportunity for toronto to score without
a base hit oscar hernandez at the plate
he does there's a base hit to left field
that'll drive home
springer vlady stops at second and te
oscar hernandez picks up the rbi porteo
his 68th of the season and he fought off
that inside pitch and hit it over the
shortstop in the left i felt like i was
on the mound with barnes watching it
bounder espinal slings it in for one on
first
and in time
they turn the double play 543
so two gone for the red sox in the
fourth inning see if they look at this
on the bang bang play at first tech on
the horn
and will they challenge
and yes they will
i think he's safe i think there's plenty
of evidence right there to overturn
so kiki beating the rap at first as
mentioned
jd trying to drive one here loaded up
with two down four two sox and murphy's
1-2 pitch
line shot into left field a base hit
[ __ ] is in
the second run in a two-run
base hit to left to drive in bogart san
hernandez and the red sox lead it six to
two
j.d with his second knock today
looking at that third hit
there's another shot into left field
gonna send the runner here comes debra
as the throw to the plate
and he's safe he got in there with the
hand charlie ramos at home plate was
right on top of it and saw him get the
hand in there the red sox leaded
7-2
that ball beat him by a mile what an
outstanding slide by devers and he's had
a little bit of a down home stand
ranking bar hit high
[Applause]
a two-run home run for vladimir
riverwood jr his 35th of the season
garrett richards doesn't give up many
home runs but the blue jays get him
again they hit him for three home runs
back in july in buffalo when he stays
within himself it's a pretty special
thing that was a curveball that he went
down and got at the blue chase two more
runs got him a little bit closer
and vladi's going to take that maybe
it's the start of something special
again
bobby dolby who could use some good
vibes right here two on two ouch
swinging a line drive up the middle and
into center field to base hit it splits
the middle infielders jd rounds third he
will score without a throw redemption
for dolbeck and it is 8-4 red sox
excellent job by dahl back there taking
a pitch on the outside edge and just
going right back up the middle marcus
semi in the batter oh for three
1-1 pitch
fly ball hit into center
springer is tagging he'll come in to
score the throw is
all the way home but springer is in
safely
it's a three-run game
blue jays down three hernandez back in
with a couple of singles and a ribby
today avino set and comes home swinging
a line drive base hit into right center
field bloody cuts the corner at third
he'll come home without a throw on an
rbi single by t oscar hernandez it's a
two run game
8-6 boston
tay oscar hernandez taking advantage of
the guerrero stolen base blue jays pick
up the quick run nobody has enjoyed
their new confines more than george
springer tying runs on the 2-2
springer drives it in the air deep left
field you can forget it a go-ahead
three-run homer for george springer the
blue jays are all the way back what a
party happening on the near end of the
blue jay dugout springer with a
three-run go-ahead home run 9-8 toronto